basically  um  [Music]  two months two months and then a half  yes  good size yeah she's tall she's tall  ended up to be like yeah yeah it's my  mom by the way yeah  oh yeah how do you enter the building  it's just from the building one but you  need to swipe your car  because yeah because i can't enter right  with your card you're kind of straight  building 10. you're in 10 lockdown ah  okay  so it's only one two 11 open so how  would i because i scheduled meetings you  know  to be in level nine uh do you want to do  in library library maybe where  because i haven't checked the library  okay  [Music]  wizard central  i'm so famous  yeah i just gave birth so i like i was  there yeah yeah yeah  boy a girl  thanks so much yeah super easy is the  mobile streamer buddha library epidemic  bye-bye  [Music]  professor  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  you